I woke up at 5.30 this morning, freezing and disoriented and threw up my temperature with 104
Tim, husband, gave me one ibuprofen, brought my temperature down to 100
barely quickly. It stayed down a little 100 on its own, but it's now climbing again 101.8
a few minutes ago. My main symptoms are chills, fatigue and headache. I call my ecologist
requested a blood test. I emailed those to you. My part was installed four weeks ago. It has been
newly sore over the weekend, but shows no obvious signs of infection. What do you think?
So I screen-jotted the labs that this person said because I think there's a lesson in this.
So here's this is a CBC with the Virgil. So CBC is white blood cell and red blood cell
hemoglobin, all the breakdowns of the red cell line platelets and then a breakdown of the white
blood cell line in percentage and total absolute count here. So we want to look at this. Now different
labs have different normal values. Some normal values of white blood cells are 4.5 to 11 like this.
Other labs might be 4.0 to 10. But quite honestly, anything really over six, you think you have
something going on. So white blood cell 7.1, you think there's something going on right off the
mat. Now we're going to go back, come back to the white blood cell in just a second. Let's look
at the rest of this test. Red blood cells 4.1 died just on the edge of low. So that is
by definition edemia. So even when you have low red blood cells, even close to low, you have edemia.
Now what will happen with edemia is that you'll have other of these red blood cell components
be out of line as well over time. So all of these, the hemoglobin is still with a normal range,
hematocrit, the mean cell volume, and all these other components are still within normal range.
So that tells you that either A, this is an early edemia, which is good. You know, you don't want
a more chronic edemia. Or B, this is what's called an acute edemia. So if the person has acute
blood loss, so if the person has acute blood loss, let's say they just started having a bleeding
ulcer yesterday, and they have black stools, black tary stools, that's what would happen if you had
a bleeding ulcer, and you could have low red blood cells with no other other red blood cell components
be abnormal. Or if you have an early edemia, so let's take a step back, there's different types
of edemia. There's edemia of a chronic disease, which is the most common edemia cell found with
cancer patients. So the most common type of edemia found with cancer patients is called edemia of chronic
disease. That's the, that's the, uh, technical name for it. And you will see low red blood cells, you'll
see low hemoglobin quite often. Uh, hematocrit can be low. The mean cell volume and MCH, MCHC will be
typically elevated in edemia, chronic disease. And these are components of the red blood cell itself.
So the volume of the red blood cell will be enlarged. The size, the volume will be enlarged, the size
as it's measured will be enlarged because it's tried to carry more oxygen. So that and the red cell
width will be elevated typically as well. So that's typically edemia of chronic disease. Then you
could have edemia of B12 deficiency, and that looks a little bit different, and I won't go into that.
And then you could have some, you could have a folate edemia. So there's different types of edemia
that you look for, but almost always which are cancer patients, it's going to be edemia of chronic disease,
where red blood cells, hemoglobin, hematocrit may be suppressed, and the rest of these are going to
be elevated. That's not uncommon at all. So we don't see any of that yet. So that's a good thing
for this patient. We have some early edemia going on. That's certainly not what's causing the fever.
Okay. So whatever you have fever, you think of infection. What is causing this fever? So the medical
doctor may look at this and go, I think you're fine because your white blood cell code is still with
a normal range. So this person might have a normal white blood cell code of 4.5, and that would be
would be normal in this case. If this person has a history of cancer, they could have a normal
for them white blood cell code that is suppressed of 3.0 because they've been dealing with
fighting cancer. And now a white blood cell called a 7.1 is highly elevated. So I think 7.1 is
elevated anyhow. So then you look at the breakdown of white blood cells. So here's the breakdown of
white blood cells. If the person has elevated white blood cells, and I would define this as elevated
white blood cells, if they have elevated neutrophils, think that it's a bacterial infection. Well,
this person doesn't have elevated neutrophils. Neutrophils is within normal range right in the middle.
So it's probably not a bacterial infection. If they have elevated white blood cell code,
side of infection, fever, nausea, blah, blah, blah, blah, and they have elevated lymphocytes,
that's this right here, lymph percentage. No, that's not it either. But if they had elevated lymphocytes,
think viral infection, viral infection. If they have elevated eacidophils, that's EOS right here.
That's what this person has. Think allergy. So this is just in general. So elevated eacidophils
think allergy. So, in fact, this person's absolute lymphocytes code is actually low.
So why would they have a low lymphocytes code and possible elevated white blood cells? You know,
if the other thing that tells you is that for them, without this fever, their white blood cell code
is probably lower than 4.5. The fever caused it to be up to 7.1. So eacidophils allergy possibly,
here's the absolute eacidophil count is elevated as well. So what could cause an allergy? Could be
something they ate, could it have an acute sensitivity, acute reaction to something that would not
necessarily be out of the question. Could be food poisoning of something like that. That's what you
think of with a blood test like this. I would not think that it has to do with an infected port.
An infected port, you'd think of bacterial infection and you'd see an elevated neutrophil